what are what are you independent about
yeah go no what are you doing
what the holiday is
christmas what are you christian about
memorial day what do you think it is
okay no what are you independent about
um
comedy comedy content i think you should
answer this question to be honest with
you well that i was you know he was
doing a little yeah yeah segway here
yeah man
we got to think of [ __ ]
i was just just just rolling
just swirling this is word swirling bro
no um obviously uh i hope everybody
listening right now knows that we uh
just dropped the first like promos for
the the special infamous coming out boom
and uh
yeah and uh everybody here in this room
played a major part in that so i'm just
super grateful for everybody here in
this room and obviously everybody that
has been so supportive online and going
out there and pre-ordering it yo go
pre-order it man go pre-order it uh when
does it drop it drops the 17th july 17th
as well army light this thing the [ __ ]
up please because this is an absolute
game changer if we can do this you know
obviously you guys
heard the story uh we just did not want
to compromise material
and um
they just did not want to compromise
it was like entire businesses yeah we
don't blame them yeah i mean there's
multiple bits like multiple even lines
and other bits and like i get that i
understand i have empathy for people who
are in that business right because
they're not creating the content right
they're making sure that their business
is successful right so like
i'm not angry necessarily that they're
protecting themselves and to be fair
like the person that's at the streamer
was
on my side but everybody got a boss yeah
and a streamer is bigger than any one
project exactly because
it's your whole audience yes you know
like when you have a youtube channel
you're putting out your content on that
channel and you can curate what that
audience is into and the people who
don't like it just don't watch it but if
you're one of these streamers you got to
deal with [ __ ] kids shows to adult
shows just absolutely everything
so so yeah but uh they didn't really
want to
you know they want us to make some cuts
and we're like listen
you know i've had enough of that what's
the point what's the point of being
independent what's the point of doing
this [ __ ] what's the point of creating
your own stuff we're gonna write the
jokes we're gonna edit it we're gonna
put it all out and
we have the opportunity to do it we go
in front of audiences and do this all
the [ __ ] time we know what's funny
and what isn't we know where the [ __ ]
line is you know people like it you know
it works the the the [ __ ] audience is
the one that gives me the notes yes do
you know what i mean like yes i'm on
stage if the joke's bombing i know it's
not good yeah the joke is killing i know
it's good right and we're in front of
thousands of [ __ ] people literally
hundreds of thousands if you look over
the course of the tour like we know what
the people can take and what they can't
take and
i don't know like i just wanted to trust
that relationship i have with them like
i s you know you see a lot of people
[ __ ] on comedy that's coming out
from these streamers yeah it's like
i built my career in the beginning i
started it
by doing comedy that they would never
allow on these companies right or these
networks common centers would never
[ __ ] allow it to be on there
and
it was very successful and i assume it
was very successful because people are
like oh [ __ ] this is the real yeah this
guy's being authentic this guy's being
real he's being truly funny this is kind
of how i like to bust balls with my
friends these are the ideas that i like
to see made fun of
and
for me to sacrifice that when i finally
got to this point where we put all this
work into making this [ __ ] special
and something we're all i believe very
proud of i can't speak for you guys but
i think that we're all very proud of
this [ __ ] piece
and to be at that point and then go i'm
just going to water it down so it can be
acceptable it's like why we work so hard
that why we [ __ ] put all this work in
what's the point of that yeah why we
sacrifice so much why we away every
[ __ ] weekend to just put something
out there we're like oh well it would
have been nicer if i was able to say
this or this joke would have been
funnier if i was able to say that
so can you say specifically like what
things are jokes michael jackson joke
that they're like there's no way there's
a another like serial killer i love that
bit thank you man i love that and they
were like there's there's parts of that
they're like there's no way and then
just other like specific lines in it
and um
and the thing about like you know people
who have obviously seen the live tour
they've
when i do a bit it's like a piece right
so it's like it can be five minutes it
can be ten minutes but it's like a chunk
that has layers and it takes
months and years to build these out i
know that sounds crazy
because a lot of times you'll see the
crowd work stuff and i'm just doing it
in the moment but like to put together
the abortion clip that i dropped like
that took years to put together right
and it's just like
the
i guess what i'm trying to say is like
to just lop that off or change it
it it's that that that would be very
difficult
yeah you know very very [ __ ]
difficult so
i want to um
maintain the integrity of the piece and
that took you know us
buying it buying it back
basically long story short took us
buying it back and then
and now we're delivering it right to you
guys
and i think the cool thing about this is
that if this works and again this is a
gamble who knows what works if you guys
decide if it [ __ ] works if you guys
support it [ __ ] army i hope you guys
do but if it works
and comics find out that they can make
more money doing this than doing
traditional network specials
there'll never be a note again on comedy
yeah
so
and then what will happen is the
networks will go oh [ __ ]
we can't offer them the money
because they can make their own money so
we have to let them do whatever the [ __ ]
they want on this on on the specials and
that's the thing with the streamers
right now that people aren't saying but
i think everybody's kind of realizing is
it like it's not giving you the people
that it used to give you yeah back in
the day you go on a [ __ ] streamer you
become
a superstar yeah it's not really making
superstars no more but they could still
pay you crazy money yeah yeah now the
sudden the money drying up mm-hmm right
yeah now the money ain't what it used to
be yeah the stock prices are down for
everybody it's it's a tricky worlds
out there and
they don't have as much money to go
throw around so if you can't offer the
people
compared to a youtube yeah and you can't
offer the money what's the point yeah
andrew censoring on top of that that's
so that's just like there's no people no
money
and it's censorship
can't do it there has to be another way
i don't know if this is the way i
[ __ ] hope this is the way it would
i mean it would make me so happy
not only selfishly that we could do well
with this
but also to like create
pure authentic
comedy like
the exact way you want to do it
that is that would be really cool yeah
that would be really [ __ ] special and
i'd be very proud of that
i'd be very yeah i'd be very [ __ ]
real quick walk people through how to do
it what's the deal so like go to the
andrews.com yeah just go to the website
and then there's a click and it'll take
you to moment house and shout out to
moment house moment house is a is a
company that uh that we're working with
and also they've they've done other
versions of like live shows so you could
you could uh you'll be able to watch the
special and exist there for two weeks
and then we're gonna email everybody who
orders a special a private link of it so
you'll have it forever so when you get
it you just get it forever yeah we're
also talking about house we might just
keep it up there in perpetuity so you
can have that or the link but yeah i
know it says the two weeks maybe that's
confusing but you'll just have this
special forever and um
yeah i'm just [ __ ] stoked i'm stoked
we got to do it the way we got to do it
and i [ __ ] hope it works and so proud
of you thank you man i'm proud of you
guys and the amount of work that went
into this you know like mark alex shifty
like the [ __ ]
hours of editing that we put into this
dove like
valla you probably did something but
like
you know what i mean like we yeah we
just put a lot of [ __ ] work into it
and
i don't even like
talking about that because we should put
work into it i don't want you to feel
bad for us like we love doing this and
that's what it is and
but uh
what i'm most proud of is like it is the
exact special that we want to put out
from the [ __ ] sound to the color to
the
jokes to everything this is what we want
to put out and if this is a new way
where we can do this and [ __ ]
can make more money than they go with
the streamers like why would you and
then it's yours you do whatever you want
with it it's not a network like oh you
can't put that clip on youtube and
you're like well it would be great for
people to see it
no now it's yours you do whatever you
want you get people to see it in the way
that you feel yeah if you're working
with a streamer do they prevent how much
you can put on you of course of course
this many minutes you're like but what
if this joke could really do well and
get people to watch my special we don't
care and you kind of don't know what
joke is gonna pop and what is especially
with like tick tock you don't know
what's gonna hit the algorithm
so if i'm limited to 10 of my material
it's like well [ __ ] dude one of his
other 90 could have been exposed so many
people could [ __ ] with me and [ __ ] with
this style of comedy and they're just
not gonna know yeah i'm just tired of
the [ __ ] censorship with jokes [ __ ]
like
it's just so stupid like
it's one thing if you're just winging it
it's another thing if you're on a tour
in front of lots of [ __ ] people and
these jokes are working every single
yeah people don't enjoy bombing with
offensive jokes over and over and over
it's not a thing i promise you if you
did it once you wouldn't do it again
you would try your hardest to never do
it again yes at the other day we want
the feedback we want the rewards i want
to do well i'm needy we are insecure
people that's why we do we don't want to
offend you and you hate us we want you
to love us on our terms a little bit
yeah yeah yeah we're filming the
audience so we are actually capturing
their immediate reaction so and you're
like the biggest youtube guy though so
is there a reason you didn't just put it
like some people were dming me that like
why don't you just put it straight on
youtube i need to make money
that's the [ __ ] reason because
it costs a lot of goddamn money are you
allowed us yeah not even to at least
break even to break eve that's yeah
that's the other thing it's like
[ __ ] there ain't no cash grab
here yeah it's let's make it back yeah
you know and that's but to me i don't
know i think it was worth it how good
does it feel to own your [ __ ]
if yeah it feels [ __ ] great it feels
great to put it out when we think it's
done yes that's the other thing it's
like you're on a different timeline
i think we got
uh i think we got used to creating our
things like when it's ready putting them
out you know what i mean and like but
when you're working with corporations
like they they have every right to want
yeah what they want and they have they
have every right that that is how they
also make money that's their business
they feed their families like i
completely respect that but when you
create something that's so [ __ ]
personal to you and
you know i'm sure you guys feel this as
well because this is your creation too
so it's like
you're like not that it could be better
yeah it could be this i remember that
with the netflix thing which was great
but like it was like oh i wish we could
have one more day i want to give a sport
no we have to because the subtitling and
the whatever and the international
release like it was even like bring back
a poo like like you need an extra like
we took an extra two days and everything
was it changed everything yeah imagine
you want a deadline with the network
that was like no it has to come out
today it would it would be 15 20 worse
and i empathize with two less days
because because they need to do it at
certain basketball games need to be
played yeah like the finals need to be
you're injured
we sold 30 000 tickets for [ __ ]
to come on this day at this time that's
it you can't disappoint these 30 000.
that's it that's what it is so i i get
that i'm not angry at that but once you
feel
freedom
once you feel like creating something
and
putting it out the way you want to put
it out
it's hard to go back it's like just the
idea of freedom in general like once
that popped up whoever the [ __ ] said i
don't know if it was a french dude i
don't know who the [ __ ] was like yeah
you should be able to be free to do
whatever you want like once you put that
in motherfucker's heads it's hard to go
back yeah like it is hard like
i don't know like oh this needs one more
day i want to change this one little
thing and then you see it and you're
like i'm so proud of it
and uh
yeah i just want to do the jokes i want
to do and i are you know everything that
we've been working towards is finding a
way to put out the content that you want
to put it out put on your own terms and
give it directly to the people this is
the first time i've ever sold [ __ ]
comedy i don't know how that was gonna
go
for five years i've just given away
specials and clips i i'm hoping that
people appreciate that and i'm hoping
that people
will want to support me in this and uh
yeah
[Music]